Hollywood Police Chief Tom Sanchez is
with us now he's also at the nursing
home which as you might expect is now
closed chief Sanchez thank you so much
for joining us this is just a
heartbreaking story
thank you sir this is a heartbreaking
story on many levels the ages of the
patients the conditions in which they
died the temperatures and then to know
that the the power wasn't working that
the power was working but the air
conditioning was not I know that the
investigation is in its early stages but
what can you tell us about what you have
learned so far so listen thank you
you're right this is a tragic event you
know the senseless loss of these eight
individuals lives as as a timeline you
just reported when we the police got
here at 6:30 we assisted with evacuation
as soon as the 158 other patients were
evacuated outside the facility we sealed
the facility as a crime scene
we worked hand-in-hand with Memorial
Hospital right next door and our fire
department to triage each of the
patients classify them as their need of
care get buses here we inundated the
South Florida area hospitals with these
patients we set up a tent for families
and a phone number for them to be able
to know where they can find their
families why do you think it took so
long for officials to realize that this
was a very serious situation right we're
looking into that now I can tell you
that it's not uncommon for Fire Rescue
to respond here we responded here over a
hundred times last year four different
types of medical calls so the first call
that was a cardiac arrest around 3:00 as
you stated and that person was taken
over to Memorial Hospital sadly enough
that was one of the patients that passed
away just a little bit after 3:00 in the
afternoon yesterday and then by the
second time the call came difficulty
breathing the fire lieutenant
the third time they came out they
sounded the alarm they started notifying
people and then that's when the response
came in and as fire crews were inside
she determined that three other in the
have passed away chief how many other
nursing homes I've heard as many as 40
in your area team may not have
electricity right well that's a very
good question as a preventative measure
I sent out officers to all 42 nursing
homes yesterday there was one that we
found that did not have sufficient
electricity and it was very hot inside
us as was the nursing home to hear that
were investigating we made the
determination to have that nursing home
evacuate it was very small and the five
patients were brought also here to
Hollywood Memorial Hospital you know I
can tell you that in one positive of
this is the department was ready my day
started out yesterday morning addressing
230 police officers and at 7:00 a.m. as
they came on shift to deal with the
hurricane aftermath
you know we luckily it did not get hit
by the storm but we had extensive damage
throughout the city and power outages
more than 130 cops were manning traffic
like some of them have been on shift for
more than 10 days and so we had all the
detectives already working they were
part of the first responders that came
out here to help with the evacuation so
the investigation was able to start
quickly with only police department that
I know of that two years ago started a
program I know with the state agency for
that investigates the health
administration department Chiefs and
while to every yes ma'am I was just
gonna say I know how stretched thin and
how your team is working so hard and so
thanks to all of them and I know you're
working so hard to make sure this
doesn't happen again so thank you so
much for all that that your team does
thank you ma'am